[Music]
sally thank you right now
election workers in clark county are
actually recounting votes in the
district c
race that is the one that's actually
separating winner ross miller from his
opponent stavros anthony
by just 10 votes and the i-team has
found for one of these candidates
it's happened before the ice team david
charns is outside
election headquarters in north las vegas
with more on when we'll get these new
results
we expect to know more tuesday about
when we could get the results of this
recount the deadline is friday
but keep in mind that the work happening
in the building behind me is going
much faster than what we saw during
election week but first let's go back
11 years the i-team found in the 2009
election anthony won his seat on the las
vegas city council by 10 votes
and that's the same margin in this race
in that first election his challenger
asked for a recount
which later found no difference and
anthony was named a new counselor by
that 10 vote margin
right now the county is tallying up
those votes made in person on voting
machines
then mail-in ballots will be fed into
the system again
but this count will not include all of
the ballots found to be invalid like
those without matching signatures that
process
is already over before they were coming
in they were getting scanned into the
mail ballot processor
signatures had to be verified and went
to the county board all of that work is
done
anthony's campaign requested this
recount it has a price tag of 80
thousand dollars again the deadline to
get an answer is
friday but they are working from 5 in
the morning
until 10 at night every day here in
north las vegas so we could have an
answer before then
in north las vegas i'm david charns 8
news now